hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2021 american science fiction and
thriller movie called awake
the movie starts with jill adams a
former u.s army medic and ex-drug addict
who currently works as a campus security
guard through her old friend named dr
murphy she secretly steals expired drugs
from the college science lab and later
sells it to greg a local drug dealer
for one reason or another jill lives
separately with her two children
after work she visits her teenage son
noah and her younger daughter matilda
who currently stays with her grandmother
doris noah does not seem to like her mom
a lot as he shows no interest while
talking to her mom presumably due to her
history with drug abuse while driving a
mysterious global event appears causing
all electronics related devices to stop
working including cars
suddenly they are hit by a black suv
crashing their car into the lake jill
and noah manage to escape from the car
but they can't find their younger
daughter luckily matilda who was
previously drowned is saved by a police
officer the police say all electrical
power is all shut down and they are
unable to call the ambulance so they
have to walk
upon arrival they discover that the
situation has become total chaos but
jill finds out about a unique event in
which all of the coma patients have
suddenly woken up
not being served they decide to return
to jill's mom's house
it turns out that after the mysterious
event jill noah and doris are unable to
sleep except matilda jill then off to
work because she works in the night
shift on the way she discovers that the
whole neighborhood is awake and having a
party since the power's out jill meets
greg who asks for more pills and is
willing to pay double as the demand
increases
she arrives at the campus but can't find
anybody inside when she tries to steal
the expired pills she is caught by the
military army and dr murphy
dr murphy explains that people appear to
be no longer able to sleep and states
that she is starting a hub to find the
answers to save humanity because soon
people will suffer from the symptoms of
sleep deprivation
she then hands over a piece of paper
containing the address of the hub to
brian and leaves
jill tells brian that her daughter is
able to sleep and he suggests bringing
her daughter to the hub as there is
currently an old woman at the hub who
can also fall asleep and is being
studied
realizing that her daughter may be in
trouble jill rushes back home but unable
to find her as she is in a church with
her grandmother brian suddenly appears
at their home and urges jill to take her
daughter to the hub but is rejected
the people in the church finally
discover that matilda is special and
they want to sacrifice her hoping that
she would save humanity the situation
becomes heated up as jill noah and brian
arrive at the church brian explains that
jill needs to be taken to the hub
immediately so that the cure can be
found but people won't listen and brian
ends up getting shot by an officer
the situation becomes chaotic and
matilda runs away but is chased by the
people
fortunately jill manages to find her
daughter who is hiding with noah the
family flees to the woods
noah suggests bringing matilda to the
hub as he found the address in brian's
jacket before but jill insists that she
cannot be taken there because she does
not trust dr murphy and it is unsafe
there he then emphasizes it will be
useless and matilda would not be able to
survive without jill and noah if they
die eventually they agree that they must
go to the hub and find the cure
jill leaves her children outside and
sneaks into a car garage to find an old
vehicle two men in the garage managed to
start the car by boosting an old vehicle
battery
suddenly they spot a military car
containing meds passing by and decide to
chase it leaving the old car
jill manages to steal the car after
hiding from two men picks up mantilda
and noah and proceeds to the hub
on the way they discover a crashed car
in the middle of the road the drivers
are dead so jill steals their gun and
continues the journey they stop at a
library to find a map leaving matilda
who is sleeping in the car
while mapping suddenly numerous
prisoners escape and one of them steals
the car with matilda in it and drives
away
other prisoners threaten jill and noah
jill tries to point the gun at the
prisoners and shoots once but
unfortunately it is her last bullet
luckily they are saved by dodge the
prisoner who stole their car
they stop at a plane wreckage dodge
manages to find the clothes he needs as
he is still wearing a red prisoner suit
while jill teaches matilda some basic
survival tips as the only one who is
still 100 awake jill teaches her
daughter to drive
while driving they are attacked by
random people but manage to escape
they finally arrive at the entrance of
the hub
dodge offers them to help but is
rejected by jill and she tells him to
leave with the car
jill splits up with her children and
sneaks into the hub she manages to get
into the lab in the hub and disguises
herself as a lab worker she finally
talks to the other old woman who can
sleep but she is currently in a very ill
condition
she plans to free the old woman and asks
her to raise matilda for her because
jill believes that everyone except her
and matilda will die the old woman
states that she should have died months
ago
suddenly jill is approached by dr murphy
she says that they haven't found any
cure for the disease yet and can only
rely on a drug that can buy them time
but it will damage the brain
she also thinks that in the end everyone
is going to die
desperate jill walks out from the lab
and sees a pair of flares are being
fired by someone it turns out that dodge
comes back with her children
they are stopped by the soldiers and
matilda tearfully admits that she is
able to sleep and willing to be a test
subject
the next day matilda sees a poor ape
whose head had been cut open revealing
its brain
turns out that the ape is also
experiencing a sleep problem just like
humans due to genetic connection jill
was right not to trust dr murphy as soon
as she finds out about matilda's
specialty she is prepared to cut the
little girl's head open
when dr murphy and her team are
preparing to do a surgery suddenly the
sleep deprivation starts affecting the
military crews and the nurses causing
them to hallucinate and randomly firing
the gun
for example one of the crews randomly
kicks a pinecone and screams grenade the
situation in the hub becomes chaotic
jill hallucinates that noah is
threatening to kill her while the real
noah is taken away to see if his brain
is different from his sister on the
other side a doctor injects unknown
liquid to dr murphy causing her to die
instantly turns out that the doctor
intentionally did not remove the air
from the needle
after escaping from hallucination jill
comes to rescue matilda and they find
noah's hallucinating causing him to cut
a wire and electrocute himself
they try to resurrect him using a
defibrillator but fail
the next day dead bodies are found
everywhere in the hub
noah suddenly wakes up literally comes
back to death and says that he was
dreaming
after several days without sleep jill
seems to be dying already noah tells
jill that she was right about not
wanting to go to the hub and says that
matilda and him need her as a mom
at the very last moment matilda
discovers a sheriff's badge lying on the
ground and remembers how she nearly
drowned at the beginning of the movie
but the police brought her back to life
she approaches noah and jill and figures
out the similarity between her noah and
the old woman
the three of them had been in a
situation where they almost dead and
managed to come back to life
she thinks that it is the main reason
why they could sleep while the others
can't because they started over
noah and matilda then planned to
intentionally make her mother in an
almost death situation by drown her to
the nearby lake and then bring her back
to life
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching
[Music]